yo voy a hablar hoy de una enfermedad
fantástica le dio fantástica por no
existe este término en el diccionario
esta enfermedad se llama la bronce mya y
dicen que los médicos que la padecen ya
que bronce me etimológicamente sería la
cantidad de nivel de bronce en sangre
los médicos que la padecen a medida que
pasan los años
al comenzar invadirse con bronce creen
que son próceres y sueñan con que su
estatua de bronce
alguna vez esté en el patio del hospital
o de la clínica en el que él trabajó
este término lo escuché hace fácilmente
30 años del doctor feijóo osorio un
médico reconocido cordobés ya en un
servicio de cirugía del hospital de
clínicas acá en córdoba en el cual era
también profesor adjunto narciso
hernández porque muchos atribuyen a
narciso hernández este término de bronce
mya pero de que la que encontré la
utilice en la docencia y me quedó
grabada esa palabra para siempre decía
narciso hernández
que el enfermo de corazón he pasado por
dos etapas la primera etapa era lo
importante y tish en la que él se creía
que era tan importante que nadie era
mejor que él
la segunda etapa era inmortal y tish
cuando el paciente ya llegaba a su etapa
final con el bronce invalida todo su
cuerpo ahí si se creía que era una
estatua olímpica e inmortal
donde se desarrolla esta enfermedad y
generalmente en aquellos lugares que
presumen un alto nivel de
intelectualidad y el medio ecológico
ideal sin ninguna duda en la universidad
pero también se han descrito casos muy
severos en tribunales
es grandes sanatorios en sociedades
científicas en empresas también en
instituciones deportivas de renombre y
por qué no decirlo ayer en el almuerzo
me comentaban también en la clase
política y justamente la clase política
parece que sin antecedentes que lo
hicieran presumir la soberbia y la
solemnidad propia del bronce mico
aparecen en el político de manera
espontánea
otro dato importante es la edad
generalmente aparecen comienza a
aparecer 45 55 años pero los casos más
severos se presentan entre los 55 y 65
años que es cuando el hombre en su deseo
de disertar y hablar de cosas
que generalmente ha leído en forma
bastante superficial está en relación
inversa con su edad y su capacidad de
poder comprender y discernir el sexo
también es importante se creía que era
más que nada del sexo masculino pero
creo que ahora con el auge del feminismo
si hiciéramos nuevas estadísticas bien
concretas encontraríamos gran número de
mujeres con bronce mya y lo que todos
los autores están de acuerdo en asegurar
es crear 11.000 las mujeres siempre ha
sido caso de extrema gravedad y
prácticamente incurables
los síntomas más comunes del bronce mico
son 3 la diarrea mental
la hipoacusia interlocutoria
y el reflejo de falo caudal la diarrea
mental se caracteriza por una
verborragia exagerada en la que el
bronce mico habla y habla todo lo que su
cerebro le pone generalmente habla
erguido y como si estuviera hablando
desde un púlpito de arriba de un atrio
la sordera interlocutoria acompaña
siempre la diarrea mental
cuando el bronce mico habla y habla y
habla sus oídos no escuchan nada cuando
el bronce mico habla no escucha nadie y
el reflejo céfalo caudal es la que lanza
forma tan característica de caminar con
la cabeza elevada la cola parada por la
impregnación de bronce y algunos autores
dicen que
el bronce comienza a depositarse primero
en los pies y después sube hasta llegar
al cerebro y si esto fuera cierto
posiblemente justifique el hecho de que
los bronce micos desde el comienzo de su
enfermedad ya no caminan se desplazan
majestuosa mente
esto de la bronce ya que pensaba que era
una cosa actual no es así
les voy a contar mil 500 años antes de
cristo cuando se realiza en la antigua
india la separación de las castas
sociales en cinco castas la la quinta
casta era la de los intocables aquellos
que no tenían derecho a nada ni siquiera
tenían derecho a la atención médica la
cuarta casta era de los trabajadores
inferiores la tercera casta de los de
los comerciantes y la segunda cartera la
casta de los andas estás a la que
pertenecían dos médicos y la primera
casta la de los reyes estados la primera
y la segunda castas decían que
descendían de los dioses pienso que tal
vez algunos américa bronce micos creen
realmente que descienden de los dioses
de la historia de la medicina también
todos hicieron hablar de galeno galeno
de pérgamo era un médico que creció en
la roma imperial en el año 162 y era un
broche mico un ególatra incorregible
hablaba permanente
de sus grandes ganancias de su de su
fama y revestía todas sus curaciones de
una manera milagrosa como para poder
impresionar más a la gente pero en la
época actual ahora estoy seguro que
cualquiera de nosotros en el lugar donde
desarrollamos nuestra actividad y
cualquiera sea ella estoy seguro que
debemos convivir con bronce micos y
quisiera darles un dato que sé que es
muy preciso y precoz muchos autores
dicen que uno de los primeros síntomas
que aparecía en el bronce mico es que
comienza a perder la capacidad de
sonreír
no voy a seguir hablando de d
de los síntomas del bronce mico pero
creo que es importante en esta charla
decir que podemos hacer para que
nuestros jóvenes médicos o para que los
jóvenes no se contagien de bronce' mya
yo creo que únicamente podemos hacer con
todos nuestros esfuerzos tratar de
imbuirles en su cerebro en sus mentes el
deseo de ayudar a sus colegas a sus
colaboradores a sus pacientes de sembrar
dentro de ellos para que florezca el
espíritu de servicio y quiero distinguir
entre servicio y espíritu de servicio
recuerdo hace muchos años cuando estaba
haciendo mi tesis doctoral en la sala de
cirugía experimental
vi un conejo que le sacaba a otros
conejos los hilos de estructura de lomo
lo habíamos operado de una cirugía el
hombre
esto de sacarle los puntos un animal a
otro no es extraño el escalada animal
incluso animales de distintas especies y
sacan las espinas o los cuerpos extrañas
lo que este conejo estaba haciendo en
ese momento que estaba haciendo al otro
un servicio porque el servicio ese es
eso un acto que puede ser instintivo y
no necesitar la razón
en cambio el espíritu de servicio es el
profundo deseo de satisfacer a aquellos
que necesitan de nosotros no es un acto
es una actitud es una función de vida
sin los médicos jóvenes no se preparan
para nutrirse intensamente del espíritu
de servicio están preparándose para
contagiarse de bronce' mya
hablábamos del espíritu de servicio la
forma de inculcar los pero
estas cosas yo no puedo ordenarle a mi
médico jóvenes por decreto no les puedo
decir a partir de mañana piensen así a
partir de mañana comiencen a querer a
sus pacientes eso no es posible pero si
podemos ayudarlo con el ejemplo
cotidiano para que esto pueda aprender
dentro de sus corazones
dentro de sus deseos imperiosos de
ayudar a sus colegas y a sus pacientes
le voy a contar un cuento para que les
quiere hay un famoso pintor que había
presentado una exposición que se llamaba
las puertas del corazón eran puertas de
distintos colores la exposición era un
éxito puertas hermosas colores
combinados pero de un personaje dentro
de la sala que se paraba dentro de cada
puerta la miraba y pasar a la otra
de pronto se para delante de una justo
al lado de él está el pintor entonces
humildemente el hice veas discúlpeme la
puerta que usted pinta son hermosas pero
yo soy cerrajero y quiero darle mi
modesta opinión
veo que su puerta no tienen picaporte
como se van a abrir y el pintor le dice
mire he pensado muchos años pero la
puerta del corazón no tienen picaporte
el lado de afuera porque solo se abren
del lado de adentro
estoy seguro que ustedes han compartido
con médicos bronx técnicos y me imagino
que cualquiera de ustedes podría subir
acá y contarnos cómo fue su experiencia
al lado de un bronce mico de cualquier
profesión solo voy a contar lo que le
pidieron a ver ni si es que el que es un
pionero de la medicina mente-cuerpo tres
enfermos terminales jóvenes que murieron
pocos días después cuando berni les dijo
que quieren que les diga a los médicos
jóvenes porque yo tengo que hablar ahora
en el acto de egreso qué mensaje tiene
que transmita
estos pacientes les dijieron que golpeen
en nuestra habitación antes de entrar
que es cuando se le salgan se despidan y
nos saluden y que cuando hablen con
nosotros nos miren a los ojos
ninguno de estos vidrios que encontraran
la cura de su enfermedad sólo pedían
respeto sólo querían respecto y terminó
esta charla con ese impase propio de la
edad
le voy a contar una anécdota verídica es
en una sala de operaciones una larga
cirugía cirugía prolongada que de pronto
deben reemplazar a una de las enfermeras
y cuando ésta se retira pasa por detrás
del cirujano un hombre que era
reconocido con por su espíritu de
servicio
pasa detrás de él le acaricia la espalda
le da un beso y sale
eso fue para este médico un regalo
hermoso un hermoso regalo porque esto
incluía todo el dolor y el amor que
habían sentido médico y enfermeras
juntos que habían compartido en la sala
de operaciones
esto le dio fuerzas al médico para
seguir y como diría otro cirujano amigo
mío a ese cirujano se le llenó el
corazón de música
los médicos dioses
esos médicos que desayunan con dios y
después bajan a atender a sus pacientes
estos médicos bronce micos oro bronce
micos de cualquier actividad de
cualquier actividad de cualquier nivel
sociocultural no pueden recibir regalos
así
porque se sienten tan por encima de
todos los que están a su lado que son
incapaces de compartir nada